nunca está de más practicar para
familiarizarnos con los vectores y lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
relacionar las componentes xy de un
vector con la ubicación del punto
inicial y terminal de dicho vector en el
plano coordenada a qué me refiero
supongamos que tenemos un vector cuyo
punto inicial está aquí digamos el punto
a y cuyo punto final lo voy a poner en
café y cuyo punto final está por acá y
es un punto que llamaremos b así es que
el vector se vería así y lo voy a hacer
en un color que resalte lo voy a hacer
en verde entonces déjame dibujarlo aquí
bien así es como se ve el vector este
verde sí que resalta déjame colorearlo
mejor déjame acentuar lo para que lo
puedas captar mejor
muy bien aquí tenemos el vector que como
lo hemos platicado en el plano
coordenada tiene su punto inicial en a y
su punto terminal en bit y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es dar a las
coordenadas del punto a al punto b
obtener las componentes xy de este
vector que llamaremos b empecemos
entonces estableciendo cuáles son las
coordenadas de las coordenadas del punto
a son veamos menos 1 - 2 - 3 4 5 6 7 8 a
tiene como coordenadas menos 8 coma y la
coordenada en llegue a ese 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
menos 87 es la coordenada del punto a
éste es menos 8 y este es 7 y el punto b
el punto terminal del vector tiene como
coordenadas veamos para x 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
7 coma y para y menos 1 menos 27
2 así es que dado eso cuáles son los
componentes xy del vector de pensemos en
esto nuestro vector b y tenemos como ya
hemos visto muchas maneras para expresar
este vector de una manera es usar la
anotación de vectores unitarios donde lo
que tenemos
de hecho déjame hacer es son por
principio de cuentas aquí lo que
tendríamos entre paréntesis es la
componente en x mientras que aquí lo que
tendríamos entre paréntesis sería la
componente y aquí lo que realmente estoy
haciendo es escalar el vector unitario
en la dirección horizontal y el vector
unitario en la dirección vertical y 7
puedes revisar los videos sobre notación
con vectores unitarios si esto no te es
familiar calculemos entonces cuál va a
ser la componente en x una manera de
hacerlo es simplemente calcular el
cambio en x entre el punto inicial y el
punto terminal y esto va a ser la
coordenada en x del punto terminal que
es 7 menos la coordenada en x del punto
inicial que es menos 87 menos menos 8
mientras que la componente en llegue el
vector va a estar dada por la coordenada
en del punto t
qué es dos la coordenada en vez del
punto terminal que es menos dos menos la
coordenada en y del punto inicial que es
siete menos dos menos siete y ahora qué
es lo que tenemos el vector b va a estar
dado por siete menos menos ocho lo mismo
que siete más 87 más +8 esto es igual lo
voy a hacer en azul esto es igual a 15
más y esto lo voy a hacer en color malva
menos 27 es menos 9 entonces sería más
menos nueve jota o simplemente menos
nueve j esa es una manera de expresar
nuestro vector es una manera de expresar
este vector de la otra manera recordar
que hay muchísimas notaciones que se
usan para expresar vectores lo podríamos
escribir de la siguiente manera
simplemente usando paréntesis podríamos
escribirlo como 15,9 o más bien no 15 9
sino 15,9 15 menos 9
estas son distintas representaciones del
mismo vector que también se puede
escribir como un vector columna el
vector columna
15 - 9 así es que dependiendo en qué
curso te encuentras o qué libro revisas
vas a encontrar que un vector se puede
representar en alguna de estas maneras y
esto lo podemos ver aquí 15 y indica que
el vector es 15 veces más grande que el
vector unitario en la dirección
horizontal así es que 1 ops voy a
dibujarlo aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 así es que este de aquí
déjame marcarlo bien este de aquí es el
vector
15 y este es el vector 15 y a este
vector le vamos a sumar el vector menos
9 jota que va 9 unidades hacia abajo
veamos 123456789 este de aquí es el
vector menos 9 j este de aquí es el
vector menos 9 j
esto no se distingue muy bien déjame
remarcar lo en negro menos 9 j y como
podemos ver si sumamos 15 y menos 9 j
vamos a obtener el vector b que es lo
que hemos expresado aquí o podemos decir
que la componente en x es 15 y la
componente en 10 menos 9 u otra manera
de verlo es si vas de ave el cambio en x
es un incremento en 15 y el cambio en sí
es un decremento en 9 y eso nos da las
componentes en x del vector que empieza
aquí y termina acá y eso lo obtuvimos
por como dibujamos el vector como bien
sabemos podemos hacer distintas cosas
con el vector como trasladarlo pero lo
importante es que siempre mantiene la
misma magnitud
dirección